[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom and if you're anything like me
you believe that a glass of wine at
eight pm makes you a better mom so pour
yourself a glass and let's talk about
stuff here's why I'm drinking tonight it
has been a week both of my kids started
a new daycare so it's been acclimated
them to the new daycare
it's a Friday my kids are not here I'm
going to enjoy my glass of wine we're
gonna do a Riesling because it goes down
very fast I just chewed some gum so it's
not going to mess with the gum Cheers
and that brings us to this week's topic
signs that you're a wine mom so first
what is a wine mom it's not actually a
person it is a lifestyle choice it's a
person who prefers sweats over pants
it's a person who prefer captures
different person for food it's a person
who prefers laying on the couch versus
basically doing anything else
last of all it's a person who's me time
is defined by a nice glass of wine the
thing I always say about wine mom says
you don't have to be a mom to be a wine
mom it's a lifestyle it's a way of life
that being said let's go over the attire
of a wine mom we go for comfort over
everything you see me I'm in like a very
loose shirt this is loose you can't
really see what my body looks like
underneath it also elastic waistband on
the pants that is a definite must no
yoga pants I don't get where this yoga
pants fad came up that [ __ ] is way too
tight I want something stretchy give me
something if you can't see the shape of
my butt we're good cuz it's really flat
next location the place where you are
willing to drink wine is very flexible
I'm not opposed to drinking wine in the
bath not opposed drinking wine in the
shower not opposed to drinking wine on
the toilet one time my mother-in-law
came over and she went into the bathroom
and use the bathroom before she left and
she came out with a glass of wine in her
hand
said who I think you might have gotten
this on the toilet tank and I was like
yeah I didn't and it was probably two
days old but I drank it is your mother
in love British no she's so polite that
she'll never be like you gross fish what
[ __ ] are you doing leaving glasses of
wine in your bathroom are to happy bear
your son married me still doesn't go
with gum next priorities if your
favorite thing to do is melt on the
couch with a glass or bottle of wine and
a crappy TV show welcome to the wine mom
Club babe when somebody's like hey want
to go do something it's like a special
occasion let's go somewhere I'm like oh
god that sounds great but the part about
going this Saturday night my best
friend's birthday so her party's at a
club a club
I'm gonna go because the amount of
things that I attend with my friends who
are non parents are very minimal but the
thought of having to drive to a club
first of all I have to put on something
that's tight
probably and then I'm gonna have to go
into this club and be like squished with
like a bunch of sweaty people they're
always like those creepy guys at clubs
who will hit on someone even though like
I clearly have a wedding band and ring
on me so grow what you doing I'm just
being married we are we're husband we're
husband I he's at home but do you want
me to called stop I don't want to do
that can we just come to my house I'll
put my kids to bed you'll come have your
birthday on my couch I'll get some wine
then we can just watch CSI old reruns
not the new [ __ ] oh the purple come out
next cost-efficiency when you are a wine
mom you're gonna buy smart there was
this one time at the grocery store you
bought six bottles of wine you've got
your 30% off and then on top of it you
got $25 off your groceries and having
three boys in my house it was the
greatest thing
ever we as a family spend all of our
money on food to feel alright nice water
no I don't need any water I need more
wine we spent all of our money on food
to feed these garbage disposal boys so
if I can get my wine for cheap and then
get my food for cheap
that's [ __ ] outs - I want with my that's
all I want now I know if you're just an
average person what I said doesn't sound
that exciting but if you are a wine mom
that is just the sexiest thing you ever
heard can you just anyone in a discount
groceries mmm and last moderation at the
wine mom I am a responsible parent I
love my children they're my priority
this is my me time my children are not
here I'm not responsible for them my
husband is going to pick them up from
daycare and I don't have to worry about
this it's not about getting drunk I have
a limit of about one and a half glasses
before I fall asleep and if you think
that I'm drunk because I'm slurring my
words or being silly or not remembering
what I'm about to say that's just
because I haven't slept in four years if
you had flipped in four years it's a
miracle that you're even existing let
alone talking it's all about a glass and
a half of fun and knee time and
hard-earned wine so drink up so that's
all I got for today I'm Hannah your
friendly neighborhood why mom and if
there's anything you want me to talk
about in future episodes any questions
you have for me leave them in a comment
because I read all those and I see all
of you beautiful little teenagers saying
that you relate to this on a sole basis
despite not having kids or drinking wine
and I love you that's what I'm here for
so until next time wish me luck at the
club this weekend so I'm gonna be like
trial advanced
deciding into the club while you hold
your boss the one good night what was
that what if it's like instead uh how
about oh we got it
[Music]